sony finally updated their truly
wireless wf-1000xm4 headphones
and in this video we're going to put
them head to head against the airpod
pros
to see which ones you should buy in
2021.
in this video we're not only going to
compare the design the comfort and sound
quality
but also the active noise cancellation
their ambient or transparency modes
and microphones that's something that
often is missed
sony updated their packaging to a more
recyclable
friendly one and it's interesting that
they put a sticker over the printed
packaging where it says
interesting leading noise cancelling so
i wonder what's under there do they have
to update something
let's go ahead and peel that off
interesting okay
this says noise canceling their original
print and then
they had to put a sticker over it says
industry leading noise canceling
they're stepping it up that probably
means that they wanted to wait until it
was tested
thoroughly to be able to say that so
let's see if it's gonna smoke
the airpods pro now this looks like it's
just
you know supposed to be just thrown away
right away the quality
isn't as good as the previous one but we
have our little instructions a lot of
booklets and then of course the sony's
they come with these
foam ear tips which seal in
really nicely into your ear and that
definitely helps with active noise
cancellation
and look at the size of the actual case
itself you could tell it is
so much smaller than before i have the
previous model here
look at that difference it is massive
this was really kind of
unusable you really wouldn't want to
throw this in your pocket more like a
gym bag
or messenger bag backpack but in your
pocket this size is much better now
comparing it to
the case of the airpods pro you could
see that
height wise it's actually a little bit
lower lengthwise
it's a little bit longer but as far as
the thickness we do still
have a lot of thickness so that means
when you put in your pocket
you're going to notice this thing
bulging out compared to airpods pro
one of my favorite things about these
just how small the case is you pretty
much
don't notice it in your pocket of course
we have usb type-c for
charging compared to lightning and i do
prefer usb type-c
and now both of them do have wireless
charging which is great
whereas this previous old crazy huge
case did not have wireless charging
built
in now i might as well mention battery
life as well
the total battery life for both of these
including the buds and the cases
are about 24 hours so that's similar but
what's really different is that the sony
earbuds have eight hours of charge
for the earbuds themselves compared to
four and a half hours
now that is a big difference and you may
not think that you really need that
extra battery life
but keep in mind once you're once you've
used these for a year two years three
years
that battery gets decreased and so that
extra capacity will really start to come
in handy all right let's go ahead and
open this up and
wow look at that these are actually
larger than i expected looking at the
images online
now one thing i also want to mention is
just the texture on here it looks like
the actual earbuds texture
is the same as on the outside case and i
really like it
feels kind of like cardboard kind of
like on the uh the pixel 5
and because of the material it's not
going to get all these scratches and
scuffs like on the rubber older version
so let's go ahead and grab these earbuds
out the case itself is fairly
lightweight
and let's look at the actual buds
themselves yeah these are definitely
bigger than i
expected and comparing them to the
earpods you definitely see a huge
difference
if you're angling it the same way that
it sits in your ear
or just looking at the back these are
much larger but of course
you don't have the stem that sticks down
so they can't hide extra tech and like
the battery in that section so it has to
be bigger
but i'm personally curious about how
these sonys are going to compare to the
new beats
that also don't use a stem if you guys
want to see a comparison
let us know below and hit that subscribe
button if you guys want to watch that
and you can also help us reach our goal
of a million subscribers before the end
of the year
that would be awesome now before i pop
these in the last thing i want to say is
i really like
the look and the design it's kind of a
mix of both like natural materials and
like industrial
i'm guessing this is probably a
microphone something right here but
definitely is a unique look something
that's a little different from the rest
of the headphones that are out there and
now
let's go ahead and pair these up and
i'll pop them into my ears oh there you
go
looks like they actually went into
pairing mode automatically and they did
show up we have a lot of menus to go
through i'm going to skip over those but
the one i want to point out is a 360
reality audio that is very cool just
like apple's new spatial audio
sony did it first but there are only a
few apps that are actually compatible
with that and it looks like we are all
set up
now i want to comment on the comfort i
have those large phone tips in
and they're blocking out a ton of sound
right now i'll talk about active noise
cancellation just a bit but
even without that man it is hard to hear
my voice i feel like i'm not even
speaking correctly maybe i'm not right
now but i do feel like the outer edges
here
um touching my ears so it's a little bit
less comfortable and
of course my ears definitely feel
plugged because there's no
vent like feature like we have with the
airpods pro where it releases that
pressure it makes them feel like more
open back style headphones and let's
swap these out with the airpods pro of
course i'm so used to these
first thing without the noise
cancellation i definitely hear a lot
more
sound so the sony's block out naturally
a lot these are a lot more comfortable i
barely feel them
they feel a lot lighter than these you
can definitely
feel these hold holding them up how much
heavier they are and of course
you don't get that plugged feel and then
the ear tips are more comfortable
as well all right active noise
cancellation kicked in i'm so used to
the sound already
i hear a little bit of noise from that
vent above other than that most of it's
blocked out a lot of background noises
blocked out
let's check these out and wow now i just
hear my tinnitus
up there the vent i still hear it a
little bit but uh definitely is blocking
it more
than uh the airpods pro and active noise
cancellation
oh it turns out it's actually it is on
so out of the gate it was turned on let
me go ahead and turn it off here
so um i guess naturally they don't block
out as much as i thought
still more than the airpods but that was
within with active noise cancellation
turned on so
definitely the active noise cancellation
is better on
these sonys it blocks out a lot more
sound and the low frequency sound let me
turn it back on here yeah
it does a killer job these might be the
best active noise cancellation
here earbuds that i've ever heard i'm
stumbling through my words because of
how much
sound is blocking out now how about
people's voices let's say if you're on
the subway or
walking around somewhere video go ahead
and say something hey man how do i sound
you sound very natural uh but you sound
a lot quieter so let's go ahead and take
these off all right vadim go ahead and
say something else
all right man how do these sound the
airpods you're definitely a lot louder i
can
with those i have to kind of think a
little bit to hear you yeah with these i
just kind of hear you without
needing to hear you uh let me go ahead
and switch over to the
transparency mode all right and it's so
hard for anybody to be
beat apple with these these sound very
natural the event sounds natural my
voice sounds natural
they kill in this area go ahead and say
something
good you sound exactly like exactly how
you sound
and this is going to be an even tougher
test i mean it's tough to do good active
noise cancellation but it's even more
tough to have
really good ambient mode or transparency
mode switch over to ambient
looks like it's set to 20. okay
well my voice sounds a little weird
sounds like
the high end is missing in my voice go
and talk
what about my voice is it good you sound
natural surprisingly you don't sound
digital at all like with some of the
samsung's
you still sound quieter though than you
do in real life now another
really cool thing about these is that it
has that speak to chat feature that
sony's been using
and now that i'm talking vadim go ahead
and talk hey man all right
yep it switches over there's a little
bit of a delay when it hears my voice
i'll switch over to that to ambit mode
so let me go ahead and stop talking
and then as soon as i start talking wow
that delay is actually pretty
pretty low maybe about half a second to
a second of a delay and let me stop
talking
all right there you go so um it looks
like it takes maybe about 20 seconds to
switch back to noise cancellation that's
actually good
you want to have enough of a space there
that it doesn't accidentally go back in
if you're actually talking now there's
another cool function if you don't want
to use the automatic mode
you actually just put your finger up
like this and then it's going to switch
over to ambient sound like that
and then that literally just allows me
to hear and i'm going to take my finger
off
and bam basically about a second later
it goes back to noise cancellation mode
it's a little bit extra effort
and the delay here is actually about
three seconds or so
so that's an option but the automatic
one works so well
for your voice that i think i would just
use that function now i also want to see
how that microphone works and what the
quality is but we're going to wait on
that first we're going to test out
the actual sound quality and we're going
to let you hear the music that we're
hearing as well we're going to start out
with our classic
the max tech song that everybody knows
where we started from
let me close this and pop in the earpods
and you guys will just see me enjoying
the music from one side to the
[Music]
bring other back
[Music]
all right guys i think we have the beats
of
earbuds right here because these things
have a
ton of low end a ton and high end is a
little bit
weak sounds very unbalanced but let's go
ahead and go into our eq
let's set it to how about vocal i think
that's what was really missing from that
song
let me go ahead and listen i'll go
through some of these eqs and then i'll
give you guys my actual opinions for
that song because
that factory setting was just not good
all right so for me
treble boost sounds the best and even
then it seems like it could use a little
bit more
high end so what is my first impression
well once i switched over to the treble
boost there
they definitely sounded a lot more
balanced but still had a lot of bass now
that might be great depending what you
listen to
the mids were slightly lost in that bass
now the air pods they don't sound
the best but overall they are fairly
balanced you could see
based on eq sheets that apple did a
fairly good job there so for this song
i think that the airpods pro do take the
win but let's go ahead and switch over
to our next song which is classic
[Music]
i'm a little bit disappointed the base
is
very heavy almost maybe too heavy it's
kind of the difference between
with the air pods maybe you have a nice
bose system in your car
and you have some good base because
there's an actual built-in subwoofer
and this is when you put like 215s in
the back very low
and even though i went into the eq here
and i have it set to the
to the uh what is called treble boost
preset here
i feel like i just need to go in and
remove some of this
here the other issue that i had is that
just wasn't
loud enough now do you need it to be
loud with active noise cancellation no
you don't but if you're somebody like me
and you enjoy loud music
you don't really get it from these and
then the other thing is
with the airpod pros you do have a
little bit of a space like you feel a
little bit wider than just in your ears
where these you don't have much of that
at all let me go ahead and try that
again i'm going to hit play
let's turn down the bass the clear bass
going down okay that's a little bit
better
i wish i gave our mind but i can't i
don't know guys i'm
not loving these i don't know the
clarity doesn't seem to be there and i
don't know if anybody else
has talked about this or you know about
other people's reviews
but man so let's go ahead i'm gonna
maybe
i'll pull some of these down let's go
ahead and listen to our next song
this is a rock song it's very difficult
[Music]
you guys probably saw my face there i
didn't try to make that face i just
didn't really want to listen i wasn't
enjoying the music there i actually
listened that song a couple more times
afterwards
um and i ended up with this eq and i
feel like a fool for kicking all this up
this much
but the problem is i realize with these
headphones is there's no clarity on the
high end
very little clarity if you're at bay
side you listen to hip hop
that's going to be great for you but if
you enjoy listening classical or a wide
variety of different music you want to
be balanced you don't really
get that and that's really what i was
disappointed with
and just the vocals in that song were
just hidden between all the other layers
there
and now let's go ahead and test out the
microphone it's going to be our final
test here
we'll start out with the airpods pro
this is the microphone quality that you
can expect from apple's airpods pro and
this is the microphone quality
from sony's new wf-1000xm4s
in a fairly normal room all right guys
let me know which microphone
sounded better down in the comments
section below
and now it is time for the final verdict
which one of these
should you buy well let me start out by
saying
that if this video sounded biased go
check out the comparisons against
the samsung galaxy buds especially the
galaxy bud pros
i was really shocked and i love the
sound quality they were a lot better
than the airpods
but in this case these really
disappointed me and i really spent so
much time after each sean going through
tweaking listening again
to make sure i give them the best chance
and sound quality and it just did not do
it for me
at all samsung's at about half the price
or so after discounts
sound better than these noticeably
better now
the active noise cancellation is awesome
definitely the best strong suit of
course
it's a big update compared to the old
ones but i have to say the sound quality
to me
sounds worse than the old xm3s i don't
know if they just had to make the driver
smaller
because of the smaller design and having
to pack everything into a smaller case
or what
but that just doesn't cut it and of
course compared to the airpods
these cost more 280 compared to 250 or
as low as 200 or even 190 on sale
we'll leave some links down below and
they're also less convenient in your
pocket because of how thick that case is
this actually seems like a little bit
thicker
than the old case so overall
i am a bit disappointed after that long
of a wait
because number one for headphones is
sound quality you're listening things
they don't get as loud and the clarity
is just not there for me
but that is my opinion alright guys well
let me know your thoughts down in the
comment section below click that circle
above if you guys want to subscribe
and help us reach our goal of a million
subscribers before the end of the year
we have a couple great videos right over
there
this has been max and i'll see you in
the next video